look I'm glad to be with you I will keep
this short and sweet I wasn't here
yesterday Dave's not here today because
he's sick we wish him a quick recovery
Alex Jones is on the show so you know
what that means please do consider
watching it rumble or on mug club and uh
listen to people who have been listening
on audio we've heard you I know a lot of
people have accidentally been
unsubscribed there's been something
going on with the RSS feed so please do
consider subscribing on Apple on Android
on Spotify leave a rating or review it
does help but there were 50 000
something people who it could be more
than that who were complaining that the
feed broke should be fixed please do
resubscribe or just double check
whatever app it is it back in my day it
used to be the iTunes
now it's all Apple
on with the show Bible stories
[Music]
what you doing
I'm fasting Bernie you know if you were
to endorse me for a leader of the Free
World everyone could be fasting all the
time stupid believe me I know Jesus
I'd like you to think about joining me
we can spread matching uniforms and
crippling taxes across the world you
mean stealing Democratic student so
stealing
crap I'm okay I'm gonna go back to
fasting
Healthcare free healthcare really yes
yes I'm not interested in any way
down look I I've had enough I I'm I
don't want any of your stuff
Kitty do I see
do you like free speech very much so
we're fresh out
but we do have
I can do this all day I'm okay wait wait
Endless Possibilities can't don't make
it do this song Do Da Duda when a
monthly Healthcare I'm gonna oh oh and
Jesus yeah
if you're truly God's son and I'm not
saying you are not
down from this mountain
King Joe's love oh my leg
s
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
would I know
[Music]
[Music]
that's delicious glad to be back in this
chair and the chair is actually higher
right because Dave was in the chair well
yes
I need to go wait where's the left side
that's too low this is Dave height this
is yeah this is Gerald height
[Laughter]
you've got over
under
and through there we go oh oh I just the
seam on my pants just uh oh just
I'm gonna be speaking in my voice women
you don't understand what this is this
is we'll be talking about women we'll be
talking about men we have Alex Jones on
the show we may be removed so of course
go and watch on Rumble we'll be going
through the Twitter files uh and this is
one of those things since I wasn't here
yesterday we always say if we don't hit
it first we try to hit it best give you
information that maybe some other people
have missed but
men and women is is a it's a dynamic
that we often discuss and uh women I
know you'll often say like oh it's just
you know being hit in the nether regions
as a man is the same as a woman being
hit in the chest no no no no no no no
it's an organ and I just had an organ
with my genes the scene became a high
tension cable wire you wonder what that
feels like take your kidneys wrap them
at a piano wire and cinch them oh that's
too descriptive that's what just
happened uh all right
Mr Dave we wish him obviously a swift
recovery so it's just me and Gerald a
today which may work because of Alex
Jones and I can get a little hectic how
are you yeah I'm doing well how are you
other than your you know testicles being
don't say that word that's a medical
term it's a family show it is
your your nether regions yes just wear
looser pants yeah
that's also true so we'll also be
talking about Russia again uh ganning
Rush Gannon was a villain in Zelda
Russia Banning Russia not anti-gay
Russia Banning what they believe to be
gay and pedophile propaganda okay so no
Balenciaga face masks in Russia anytime
soon or gay men kissing in public right
that that too which you know of course
you shouldn't ban that but I think it's
weird it yeah so my question of the day
to you is uh as we move on we'll be
talking with Alex Jones about his you
know with his interview with uh yay I
apologize if I dead name today it's
going to happen but the question to you
is where do you rank Adolf Hitler in
terms of worst dictators throughout
history to be really clear Hitler not a
fan and look Alex Jones you can accuse
him of a lot of things being an
anti-semite not amongst them if you have
followed him if you know anything about
his history that is not something that
you would uh you would try and label him
so uh I think that this is one of those
issues where there's been a dirty bomb
that's gone off and a lot of
miscommunications and I think we always
have to allow for the possibility that
someone can be wrong someone can be
misled and not necessarily be coming
from a position of hate even though what
they say comes out as very hateful that
can happen yeah right absolutely 100 and
I think the you'll say a little bit more
about this when we get there but I think
for the first time in history Alex Jones
was uncomfortable yes in an interview
yes he was so that was pretty comical
you could see on his face it was like
the and boom goes a dynamite yeah
oh God
[Laughter]
oh God it's really bad and I filed for
for
crying out like him and uh in in Kanye
they uh they lost uh I guess I'm trying
to think they owe how many hundreds of
millions of dollars if you add it all up
yeah and look and that's not right and
that's not fair and two things can be
true people can be wronged and people
can be uh misrepresented and they can
also say things with which you can
disagree let me just lead with this
here's kind of I don't have a lot of
Purity tests just to be clear
but I will say this when you look at
some some people on the right
um if people try and completely
eliminate you from the pool because of
one opinion in other words I do see some
people who say oh if you don't side with
Kanye that means that you refuse to name
them right some of these people who will
say that out there somebody's in actual
anti-semites no no hold on a second
maybe there are some people out there
who who think that someone like uh yay
I'll keep I'm gonna say Kanye West think
that Kanye West has some points that
they maybe agree with and maybe they
disagree with and maybe there's a
conversation to be had and I do think
that you can't silence everyone who has
an opinion as anti-semitic I agree with
that but I do think that he was off the
beam I think he was wrong and if you
have people out there who say that one
opinion disqualifies you and your entire
body of work those are Bad actors
those are Bad actors I think that you
disqualify someone if the totality of
their work for example a Mitch McConnell
or for example we'll be talking today
about a David French about a bill
Crystal about Jonah Goldberg if the
entirety of their work is consistently
to undermine the conservative principles
and the foundations of this country that
they claim to espouse that's where they
should their opinions are an eliminating
Factor as far as their validity I have
to be careful with the word eliminating
I mean eliminating Jesus from the pool
of opinions as far as voices that you
trust yes but it should never be based
on just one opinion because you are
going to disagree with every single
person on Earth rapidly on at least one
topic and that's okay for example me and
Alex Jones
I don't think the frogs are being made
gay you don't
they could be I thought that's one of
the things he was proven right about
that's true I thought they were just
born that way so I don't know frogs are
asexual I have no idea spark they
figured it out life found a way speaking
of uh Animorphs
[Laughter]
here is and I know look I should warn
you if you have kids watching this show
there's nothing uh sexual it's just
gross yeah here is a uh a tick tocker
who can be described as um
trying to think about a tactile morbidly
obese
um rotund portly unhealthy and this is
someone who wants to be an example for
your children sexualizing herself and uh
decides to self-declare
that she is hot I could have my tummy
even if it's just it's tough for clout
and if you got something to say shut
your mouth cause I'm a hot
touch
okay terrible song Here's what's wrong
with it first off I get it uh and I'm
sorry I should have warned you if you
were eating here's what's wrong with it
it's not just oh this is a big girl look
if someone is big and they're working on
themselves no one has a problem with it
no one here has ever made fun of someone
for just being big she says even if it's
for chasing clout so what is happening
we've now taken fat pride and what is it
it's just vanity
in a dishonest way in other words people
used to be vain because they thought
they were very very good looking right
they were they were uh desirable now
it's false vanity and it's demand it's a
demand that you find them attractive so
she says I'm doing this for clout well
that's not a good thing I understand
that people shouldn't have bad
self-esteem just because they're a
little bit overweight but they certainly
shouldn't be looking to find their
self-esteem and self-worth or clout in
being morbidly obese and then she goes
on to say and I'm hot
incorrect says everybody who saw that
picture by the way there's got to be
better clothing for this right it seems
like the clothing was intentionally
tight in certain areas so as to
accentuate the fat in others we are
using the term clothing very Loosely
well the closest they were holding on
for dear life yes exactly right but
she's like a tarp like maybe that might
be something appropriate something she's
a very large individual she's using the
word tummy incorrectly I think at that
size you can no longer say tummy right
no I think I'm just saying look she's
she's the one putting it out there and I
mean literally hanging over everything
else on her that's just a weird look the
problem is this this is now being thrust
upon your your children of course unless
unless you're trans and of course the
Barbie doll stereotype is completely
acceptable this is the first generation
of children who who very likely will
live shorter a shorter lifespan than
their parents diabetes is a problem
that's on the rise you look at
cardiovascular incidents and of course
we won't even get into some of the
reasons that some of the confounding
factors there some of the comorbidities
who know but we have all kinds of
cardiac problems that we're not
manifesting themselves at a young age
shorter life expectancy we have insulin
resistance this is not good it's not
healthy and where's the fact checking
where's the fact checking CDC that
actually being morbidly obese is
unhealthy and uh leads to and then
insert problems here that's the issue is
these these people have the eyes and
ears of your children and then your kids
go to a public school where teachers
yeah yeah that's just as healthy as a
liver King yeah so so and by the way
liver King is unhealthy believe me I'm
saying two extreme examples yeah exactly
and then when they go home and their mom
is trying to feed them broccoli they're
like but I don't need broccoli I need to
look like that yeah I saw it on Tick
Tock and it's fine by the way they walk
into a doctor's office
immediately no nowadays a doctor just
says no no fine we've covered the story
right obviously there could be other
things wrong but immediately it's like I
can solve all your problems I feel like
today's work is pretty easy let's just
don't be that right yeah yeah every
single part of your life that could kill
you will those those chances will go
down unless that unless the Dame walks
into the doctor's office with Gloria
aldred and he's like you look beautiful
and brave and uh just keep doing what
you're doing more of that as you are
grab a lollipop on the way you know what
grab the grab the whole jar yes I can
tell you like those
all right which brings us to something
else here is there a war on we've talked
about this before but James Cameron said
the quiet part out loud uh he was you
know plugging his new uh movie is anyone
looking forward to Avatar nope I walked
out of Avatar one just it's the last
film I can remember leaving out of sheer
boredom I just walked out I was in Los
Angeles I was at uh somewhere they tried
to save the street I was just like I
can't do this this is just so boring it
looks like a video game mixed with a
pride parade I can't I just can't do
this anymore that's true that's fair so
is anyone actually looking for comment
below Avatar too he was promoting Avatar
the way of water
[Laughter]
he had something to say and it's been
going viral and there's something here
that's more subversive that I again I
hope people are understanding what it is
that they're hearing so he told The
Hollywood Reporter a lot of things I did
earlier I wouldn't do career-wise and
just risks that you take as a wild
testosterone poisoned young man he went
on to say I always think of testosterone
as a toxin that you have to slowly work
out of your system and we'll get to the
good qualities of testosterone great
stuff I think the world could use some
more of it yeah but of course let's keep
in mind this is the trend of what
happens you saw this with Jonah Goldberg
right did super bad uh not Jonah
Goldberg Jonah uh Hill we'll talk about
Jonah Goldberg later
would any [ __ ] by another name still
be as much of an [ __ ] so uh
here is just a reminder of how he made
his bones before he decided to tell all
young men that uh their poison
I'll be back
yes
so good loves you too who doesn't like
Terminator 2
nobody
all right okay
we get it my point is and all if you
don't believe me all the references are
available at letterscutter.com if you're
not familiar with his exactly aliens
come on yeah it's okay that's Sigourney
Weaver it's less testosterone but you
know what she probably has a normally
high levels very defined jaw
it's what I call the Sandra Bullock or
Andy McDowell affection and could crack
a nut no it has we'll get to
testosterone and and this is something
that again we've talked about in general
you know us trying to feminize men and I
just think that there's been too much as
far as the scales of of gender and I use
gender and sex interchangeably because
they always were until recently with
your [ __ ] theories
um it's been tipped too far uh on the
side of femininity and there are a lot
of good things that men have done and I
don't just mean everything that you're
using that men have invented but I mean
there's a lot of good to actually be
found in the hormone and also some
people could argue neurotransmitter
testosterone but here's something before
I get to that I have always despised
James Cameron just to be clear I don't
want to be hit Hot Topic hipster here
before it was cool and let me tell you
the moment that I realized I never
wanted to hear from him again this is
how self-important people can be in
Hollywood here is James Cameron at the
Avatar Premiere quoting a language he
made up in a shitty movie that he wrote
as though it was deep watch and cringe
say in the movie
which means I see you in a means
I appreciate you and I understand you so
I just like to say coming to my cast
look at that grin
and I say we just get that settled right
now by running film so
that's enough I can't we don't need to
hear any more from that guy he quotes
his own fake language
that's the equivalent to a guy having
you know a Japanese tattoo not knowing
what it means only it's his own language
and he doesn't really know what it means
Stephen Stephen
is that what it was takame something
like that takame yeah I see you oh okay
I see and what does it mean I see you
these stupid terms I see you well yeah
unless you're blind
is that ableist I don't think so no
guy's just an absolute douchebag and now
he's going to give us advice for society
and his advice is we need less
testosterone well let me just give you
something
uh here to to chew on testosterone
levels have plummeted dramatically so
from 1999 to 2016 testosterone levels uh
for young men dropped by 25 percent
now here's what happens is when you say
toxic masculinity right you associate
testosterone with toxicity he even said
it's a toxicity
um being masculine isn't toxic now if we
want to say that abusive men men who are
violent immorally because violence is
amoral but immoral violence men who are
undisciplined men who you know men who
make up a huge percentage of our prisons
sure those are bad men but to say that
masculinity is toxic that's a problem
and then you start getting into the idea
of fundamentally altering hormones let's
get to testosterone and the kinds of
things that testosterone does ladies I'm
not sure if you want testosterone to be
continually dropping some of the
benefits uh cognition I know everyone
thinks about strength cognition
especially for older men you're talking
about attention you're talking about
processing speed executive function are
you talking about visual uh your your
sort of visual uh perception verbal
memory testosterone what else does it do
it helps to uh helps to heal injuries
yeah right helps with recovery it even
helps with elderly women who have neck
fractures
has the effects on strength are are very
very obvious just to be clear and by the
way hit the like button if you guys know
if you guys out there uh know that
testosterone is a good thing uh or women
if you like your men to have more
testosterone here's the thing
testosterone also by the way it it uh
it also has behavioral benefits this is
something that people don't realize
they'll say well testosterone can
actually result in more risk-taking and
this is true this is something a lot of
people don't know when people used to
say that women were smarter than men
that's that's not really true and men
aren't necessarily smarter than women
what you do see is men occupy both sides
of the bell curve right so men make up
almost all of our violent offenders in
prison but at a certain point the only
Geniuses left are men there are more
women who are above the average point on
the bell curve their cluster is more
toward the Middle top men occupy both
extremes of that spectrum and that can
be yes that can be in part due to
testosterone so what does that tell you
it's not the hormone in and of itself
it's how we raise young men if you have
a father to Channel all of the positive
attributes yeah that testosterone brings
guess what it's a net benefit it
effectively can be a superpower and I
use that term very Loosely I know you
guys all watch Marvel films I don't
because I'm a grown adult but for
example how dare you um testosterone
does encourage risk taking that's why
men take more risks that's why men knock
over Banks or men decide to go out on
their own and innovate new you know like
apple like computers like the internet
like fire testosterone can make men more
driven yeah sure make them more
aggressive and that's why you can have
bad men who start wars and genocide but
that's also why you can have good men
who kill those men good men who fight
the wars for the side of good do you
think that bad guys do you think that
people who want to watch the world burn
do you think they want to do without
testosterone do you know what the Nazis
did do you know the cocktail the human
cocktail they had their soldiers on
you're talking about methamphetamine
you're talking about opiates you're
talking about very likely steroids for a
lot of them because they said we want
our men as strong and as aggressive as
possible what you need are moral men who
have those same capabilities and have it
channeled testosterone is uh is
incredibly important and we all it's one
of those things we always want the war
time I always want the wartime
presidents during war Winston Churchill
they reached all the way back said we
need Churchill two years after that they
said he's not supporting a socialized
Healthcare the testosterone now is a
problem aggressivity
risk taking
these lead us to occupy both ends of the
bell curve guess what we need to teach
our young men how to channel it properly
not trying to eliminate their
testosterone because you know what you
have if men don't have testosterone they
live shorter lives they live weaker
lives they live more miserable lives
they're depressed and we have a society
that can't function by the way then
women say we're aware of all the good
men gone to well take a guess yeah
exactly women don't like this either
they end up with a bunch of beta males
and they're like is there a good man to
be found out there somebody who's maybe
going to stick up for my honor when I'm
not just going off and getting him into
a fight in on purpose in a bar or
something like that right or somebody
who's going to defend our home if
somebody should break in in the middle
of the night and threaten harm to
anybody that's in that residence you
need men to have that ability and you I
think you hit on it it's fathers fathers
are the ones that can help men
understand how to Bridle that power and
to turn it into something that is good I
remember the Gillette commercial that we
covered maybe a year or two ago I can't
remember what it was where boys were
wrestling on the ground and they were
saying boys will be boys and they kind
of repeated it in this long kind of
thing and it's like no no no we have to
break that stereotype no I do want them
wrestling and having fun and
roughhousing a little bit not only with
other kids I'm not saying beat somebody
up but I'm saying with their dad as well
that's how you learn your place that's
how you understand the limits and the
lines you can't cross with other men
right we have that kind of check bridled
strength is priceless you cannot you
cannot change the world from a position
of weakness no it's not possible good
example we've talked about it with Joe
Lewis Joe Lewis could it end all of our
lives here we live by his mercy and he
is incredibly sweet and so we're
grateful to our wonderful Lord Joe Lewis
that he doesn't go absolutely you know
God forbid he develops epilepsy and
watches anime at some point but it's
different from that in a Yorkshire
Terrier because guess what when when you
have a robber in the middle I know that
Joe Lewis is going to get to work but
it's Bridal strength and we can't give
by the way Cameron too much Flack
because keep in mind it's a little bit
tough there's a give and take depending
on the day the left is sometimes same
that testosterone is is not it's a toxin
for men it's not when injected directly
into a woman however to unnatural levels
and and just look at what testosterone
has done to Elliot page so when you see
what's happened there yeah it's just oh
wow seems a little bit self-promotion
there's another aliens coming out
is I hope not oh God I hope not by the
way this is a live show Monday through
Thursday 10 a.m Eastern you can watch on
Rumble you can listen to the audio
podcast mug Club will be doing a mug
Club extended today with Alex Jones
because I'm sure there's a lot that he
has to say that we cannot discuss here
uh on YouTube all right let's move on to
Russia here so Russia
we'd like to introduce a new segment
because there's a lot that goes on in
Russia not just the war with Ukraine
there's a lot that you may not know
about which sometimes it's important
sometimes it's relevant and sometimes
it's just hilarious and foreign enough
that it makes us uneasy which brings us
to a new segment we'd like to call
Russian and bussin
[Music]
thank you
all right there are silly people so on
uh Monday Vladimir Putin just to be
clear not fans no no fans no that was
mocking also by the way not a fan of
zelinski just to be clear no don't like
that don't like any of them and I don't
think we should be involved just to be
clear he's got an Oscar though he does
yeah for playing the piano with his dong
so uh on Monday Vladimir Putin signed
into law uh a new bill outlawing what
they uh refer to as materials that
promote
lgbtc they don't go kids yeah I'm
surprised they went with the T me too
they should have been like LG that's all
you get
the TV you will say give me BNT I say no
you do not get your LNG and even that is
a stretch here in Russia so they banned
materials that promote gay queer
whatever Lifestyles here you go for
years being gay has been extremely tough
in Russia now it's about to get even
harder
Russian Parliament
LGBT propaganda law claiming in part
it's a defense against U.S influence
I cannot put it any other way the United
States of America has become the global
Center of this sodomy
don't touch us
I mean he's not wrong don't touch us
you're just looking at something Trudeau
Don't touch don't touch me
you wouldn't got a black face and gay
hands
and very short the United States
Southern me they're just boy they stuck
that Landing it's like a nightstand yeah
there's no LGBT like the men who like to
have sex with men how does that even a
man cannot accommodate the man unless
you do something gross
so under the new law individuals can be
fined over six thousand dollars for what
they referred to as LGBT propaganda over
three thousand dollars for
demonstrations of LGBT causes
information that encourages a change of
gender among teenagers so here's the
thing some of that seems fair right
um and if we put that into uh into
effect here we could just basically
eliminate the national debt just from
the fines to Disney
so uh you can comment below what you
think about this and if you can at least
understand where they're coming from of
course I don't think that anyone should
be punished just for being gay of course
I believe that everyone should have
equal rights here in this country I
don't believe that marriage is a
fundamental human right but I believe in
civil unions that's always been my
position but I certainly don't think
that someone should be arrested for
being gay someone should be mistreated
for being gay someone should uh not
enjoy the same rights as everyone else
but I do understand them right now
trying to safeguard when they look in
the United States and they see children
being put on puberty blockers when they
see hypersexualized issues being taught
to children ages kindergarten through
third grade and you'll hear some people
say this is a boogeyman argument I hear
people from the left saying no no it's
not a boogeyman argument it's not a what
if it's not a slippery slope argument
there had to be legislation proposed to
stop it because of the policy
of the entire DNC to be clear so I
understand this reaction might be an
overreaction from Russia but you also
have to understand like with Brittany
grinder they don't share your values no
they don't see a bunch of guys with
leather chokers on floats having sex in
the Streets of San Francisco is
something they want in Russia and by the
way I would say that that's our best
export as a United States right exactly
and by the way this is a strengthening
of an already what they saw as a
Draconian 2013 law they're just
basically making it harder on people who
do these things but go back to one of
those quotes they basically said for
teenagers if you're doing a public
display for teenagers in their mind they
cannot even imagine having kids involved
in any of that right you're saying No
this is a 3 000 something dollar fine if
if only they knew it's like no but
they're looking at us and going I don't
want to be that hell my point is they
must be missing they're sitting there at
their large table going like oh they can
they can't do this with teenagers
they're not old enough what's next
having drag queen brunch with French
toast and five-year-olds stop throwing
that thing Boris come on they're not
that crazy we're talking about teenagers
they have no idea that's happened with
children from Great Schools yes and then
they just turn on the news and they're
like well son of a like oh
yeah this is so much worse all right
Boris we need new laws we need bigger
tables too quick get the student oh he
[ __ ] himself downstairs again well we'll
find the next guy you saw that story too
yes I did
he fell down the stairs and soiled
himself
whoops whoops wait really yes
he fell downstairs at his residence and
shite his pants and that's the problem
with only operating from might makes
right same thing for women beauty is
beauty is temporary yeah Putin's never
going to be as strong and powerful as he
seems especially when he trips down the
stairs and poops himself people like I
don't know if he's as a alpha as I
thought yes yes but by the way he's
outlawed stairs in the entire country
yes so it's all lifts and he is and it's
only slight Improvement he now uses ramp
in pieces all over floor
by the way it's seemingly completely
unrelated news 2500 seals were found
dead on the Russian dagestani Coastline
oh of course um so federal fisheries
they said that they weren't necessarily
sure about the cause but they would be
investigating um and actually
fortunately for us Russia Today obtained
I believe an exclusive leaked photo yes
oh well that makes sense that's uh yeah
for people listening on audio you can go
and watch it over at rumble or on
YouTube because it makes no sense but it
involves Seagal and a leather choker and
a seal perfect I was wondering where
Seagal went
yeah that's where he is yeah he's on
Mission
has yet he's never lost a fight never
never lost a fight ever when people come
up to me bad things happen
especially if they mentioned that my
hair went from bald to gray to full
black to spray paint I guarantee you if
you check that Seal's head you'll find a
bullet I can't be friends with anyone
who believes in Steven Seagal
just so you know hard pass that for me
is a purity test if you believe in
Steven Seagal is a thing we have nothing
in common you know who you are all right
before we get to Alex Jones
Twitter the Twitter files Now Dave was
in yesterday so um we wanted to make
sure that we did a deep dive and we were
able to to get all the information
possible because there's a lot to kind
of unpack and there will be more files
coming out right we thought someone was
going to come out last night but it
turns out it didn't I don't know why I
got pushed but something about needing a
little bit more time to get it all
together so why does it need more time I
don't know he does I mean he runs five
companies and has nine kids so that's
true fellow
so uh Friday of course when he released
the Twitter files and the files were
reported by an independent journalist
formerly of Rolling Stone Matt Tybee
there was a thread on his Twitter
account all the references are available
at loudofclutter.com so
here are some of the highlights but
there are some other interesting facets
here that I think some people have maybe
missed and I also think this has been
really sort of valuable as a lightning
rod to see who in the Republican Party
should not be considered amongst our
ranks right exactly so what do we have
we have the Biden team uh consistently
asked Twitter to censor material this
may not be surprising but the
specificity with which it happened is
very disconcerting so by 2020 requests
from connected actors to delete tweets
were routine one executive would write
to another more to review from the Biden
team the reply would come back handled
now
um here's the thing some of these Tweets
in question were from some small
accounts uh you can bring this up here
some of these accounts that were banned
you have relatively small accounts and
they included what they claimed were
sensitive pictures of Hunter Biden
here's something interesting you see the
big account you see James Woods you see
these big names right but I said well
one second what are these small accounts
that no one is talking about yeah two of
the accounts that were targeted they
just seem to be anti-chinese propaganda
account hmm that were banned that nobody
would really even or suspend it because
you look at the James Wood thing and go
oh okay I'm going to focus on that but
who's this other person it's always the
in-betweens it's the little stories
sometimes that give you it's and this is
why I talk about when we do what we do
we're incredibly grateful that you have
all joined and support us with mug Club
I don't know that it's possible for
people coming up today with big the way
big Tech sensors speak to create what
we've created I don't know if there's a
way for them to draft in behind us
that's a big part of what we're working
on in the new year to try and create an
ecosystem yeah where little guys
actually have an opportunity like we did
have in 2009 and 2010 2012 before the
algorithms changed it
um it's what you don't see it's not the
big celebrities it's the people who
don't have that kind of pull how are
they treated and they were removed and
stories were censored repeatedly and
that happens in the dead of night and
that is long term so much more dangerous
because you're just kind of trimming
this and you're etching that out and
then you end up framing a narrative and
no one knows it's the info you you can't
really prove but or disprove a negative
negative because he never knew that that
story existed and there's no way to find
that story that's what's so dangerous
with all of this that I think a lot of
people have maybe missed with the uh
with the Twitter files something else
that we obviously know they were
suppressing the laptop story of course
on the grounds of it being hacked
material well they knew it was bullcrap
yeah I I don't understand you always
bull crap back then yeah to be clear it
wasn't a misunderstanding it was a lie
it was a lie with which Twitter was
complicit
they claimed they thought it was hacked
and I thought well did they not just
watch our show where Giuliani brought
the laptop on air no we know according
to and I want to go to you in a second
uh here's a quote former VP of Global
Communications uh Brandon Borman wrote
in an email can we truthfully claim that
this is part of the policy as part of
our approach to addressing potentially
hacked material we are limiting
visibility of related stories on Twitter
while our investigation is ongoing
Deputy general counsel uh Jim uh Jim
Baker replied I support the conclusion
that we need more facts to assess
whether the materials were hacked I mean
the hunter Biden laptop story at this
stage however it is reasonable for us to
assume that they may have been and that
caution is may be warranted there are
some facts that indicate that the
materials may have been hacked while
there are others indicating that the
computer was either abandoned and or the
owner consented to allow the repair shop
to access it for at least some purposes
we simply need more information here's
the thing they were saying maybe maybe
not that information was available it
when you look back through history
it's not did people do
what they could do with the information
that they had at that time it's what
other information was available at that
time and were there contrarians were
there opposing viewpoints saying Hey
There is information available at this
time which was discounted for example
Anthony fauci was Aid saying that you
could catch it because it was Airborne
that a kid could catch it from his
parents through a cereal box at their
house when other people were saying no
no no no it's primarily gay sex in the
bath houses that you attend the same
thing with covet
right ah this came from a wet Market
people said well they did the best with
the information they had at that time no
no were there other people at that time
saying no no that doesn't seem to be the
case when they said hey two million
people are going to die within the next
four months according to the Imperial
College of London this is all the
information we had at this time no no
were there other people at that time who
were doctors who were scientists saying
that is incorrect at this point in time
they said we simply need more
information they could have asked us we
had the laptop on this show
hey they could have asked Giuliani they
could have asked the FBI only the FBI
raided giuliani's apartment and took
everything but the laptop they
deliberately avoided finding the
relevant information
because they knew that it wouldn't of
course support their narrative all the
while censoring the story for the entire
world this happened on all major
platforms we need more information why
didn't they go get it they could have
made two phone calls we did yeah well
and my problem is twofold with this
right and so one of them I'm going to
ask the the guys in Mission Control to
pull up pull up when they ran the New
York Times story on Donald Trump's
leaked tax returns right that fit right
into this policy like you said is the
policy applied equally Donald Trump had
been famous for saying I am never
releasing my tax returns so much so that
he was sued over and over and over again
to get them and all of a sudden the New
York Times runs a piece here are Donald
Trump's leaked read that hacked tax
returns right and they ran it nothing
now that's illegal that's illegal that's
illegal Hunter Biden was so high they
didn't pick up his computer from Geek
Squad and I know it was a computer
repair shop by the way the guy who owned
the computer repair shop said I'm
available for interview anybody I have
the receipt anyone want to tell talk
with me about it I will I will declare
this to be true under oath no one from
Twitter reached out yeah but here's the
other part of that when he just said in
the quote there he's like is there a way
for us to hide behind this policy yeah
so that we can do what we already want
to do in the first place right that's
how he said it not is this something
that fits in the policy let's look at it
objectively right sure that everything's
okay no no we want to ban this story we
want to get rid of this can we hide
behind the language well there was and
by the way there was a Democrat
representative who had a problem with
this so was uh rokana who was by the way
connected to uh uh well Rokon obviously
was connected with the Democrat Party um
and uh contacted Twitter's uh lawyer one
of their top lawyers that Vijay Vijaya
Gad I'm pronouncing it incorrectly but
here's the thing it doesn't matter
because she no longer matters no thank
God uh this is what this person said
I was concerned about the First
Amendment said hope you are well Vijaya
this throttling of the laptop story
seems a violation of the First Amendment
principles if there's a hack of
classified information or other
information that could expose a serious
War crime in the New York Times was to
publish it I think that the New York
Times should have that right and this is
even assuming that it was hacked which
it wasn't right so to restrict the
distribution of that material especially
regarding a presidential candidate seems
not in keeping of the principles of New
York Times versus Sullivan I say this as
a total Biden partisan and convinced he
didn't do anything wrong now this means
that there are some people on the left
who understood the gravity of this yeah
uh here's something that really I would
say is most disconcerting to me there
are Republicans out there there are
people who want to tear down the
conservative movement who are trying to
say that if you're a conservative and
you're you're just uh you're being a
drama queen about the First Amendment
you don't understand the First Amendment
this is a private company they can do
whatever they how often have we heard
that before all the time every single
time something comes up from somebody on
the right saying we've been
de-platformed we have been Shadow banned
we've been demonetized we're like well
sorry you guys said free market
individual companies can do whatever
they want right right right we're like
guys that you know that's not what's
going on so you've got Bill Crystal
you've got David French you've got Jonah
Goldberg and Bill Crystal maybe the just
the worst Republican ever absolutely the
worst I mean you might find someone who
maybe pants or something in the Senate a
long time ago but I don't think you're
going to get much worse in the coat room
it didn't tell anybody so David French
said that what Twitter did had nothing
to do with the First Amendment and this
is what you're hearing and by the way
hit the like button because the
algorithms tell you that we're dead on
Youtube and hit the like button if you
strongly disagree with the idea that
this is not a First Amendment issue it
directly affected the outcome of an
election anyone who was telling you
otherwise either is lying or hasn't done
their research we now know that back
then Twitter was lying
they knew that it wasn't hacked
at
at best they thought it was likely not
hacked but they decided not to do their
due diligence at worst they knew beyond
any shadow of a doubt that it wasn't
hacked and they decided to throttle it
anyway so this is David French
this is just shamelessly wrong a private
political campaign is not the government
meaning that at the time Joe Biden
because Joe Biden was reaching his his
officials were reaching out his team
Donald Trump was in office right a
political party is not the government
hold on a second
the political party that controls the
the house Chambers
a private company is not the government
it is if it's doing the government's
bidding right then it says this isn't a
systematic violation of the First
Amendment the First Amendment isn't
implicated at all this was not in any
way a private company making a decision
on their own this was a private company
doing the bidding in in by the way
flying in the face of all factual
information that we had available to us
in order to favor one political party
who by the way controlled substantial
portions of the government and were
seeking to control all portions of the
government every coup that has happened
throughout history has often
historically been militarily right
someone has some kind of a coup through
gorillas right or they somehow maybe
subvert the military get them to turn on
the current leaders right now we're in
an age of information guerrilla warfare
and so if the opposing party to Donald
Trump right we're talking about of
course uh Democrats um Pelosi was a
speaker still at that time if they can
get Twitter Facebook Google YouTube to
do their bidding that's the equivalent
to a military coup you want to talk
about Insurrection that's Insurrection
using the most powerful entities that
exist on Planet Earth Bill Crystal
retweeted an article and he argued that
Maga trolls were just mad they couldn't
post Hunter Biden dick pics jeez
by the way I was mad that we couldn't
post Hunter Biden dick pics but that's
not what's inside the book that's not
what this is about
he wrote while normal human beings who
denied Republicans their Red Wave were
enjoying an Epic Sports weekend yeah a
sports I'm sure you know a lot about
that Billy Maga activists were getting
riled up about leaked emails revealing
the troll accounts were not allowed to
post ill-gotten photos on a company
platform hey hold on a second Bill
Crystal you claim to be this is like the
Anna Navarro I used to I was a
republican okay so we get it you're not
pro-life okay so we understand it you
don't like Donald Trump but if you say
you were a Republican and you say the
party left you do you mean to say that
you were never on board with at least
the tenets of the Republican party in
theory that believed that government
should be limited that government should
not infringe on personal Liberties right
that we believe at the very least in
other words you were a republican
fiscally so then you would still have to
believe in as much decentralized power
as possible so how can you say I was a
republican but I'm really glad that the
government that the DNC coordinated with
the world's biggest Tech platforms to
censor a story that would have changed
the outcome of the election and here's
another guy Jonah Goldberg who may be a
decent man I've spent some time with him
very very briefly never been a fan of
the way that he presents uh his points
of view namely because he thinks that
he's funny
to him the story Hunter Biden and this
isn't just about Hunter Biden by the way
it's about the implication and the
corruption and uh the the the the the
strangleholds that foreign entities
could have on a potential future
president who is now the former sitting
former vice president it wasn't just
about Hunter smoking parmesan cheese
that was the funny part it was about the
Kickbacks to Joe Biden
it's about the liabilities that we would
face as a country if someone is beholden
to foreign entities which we now
somewhat see with Ukraine and amounts of
cash pledged that seem to defy reasons
so according to Jonah Goldberg though
this story didn't matter at all because
it wouldn't have changed anything which
is of course factually incorrect
about a to c they now think that if only
the media had told us about the laptop
at the time as the kid yesterday was
suggesting which I don't buy is you know
theory that Trump would have won you
know but for the censoring of the New
York Post Trump would have won and it's
I think it's a preposterous
counterfactual
but it's also an it's impossible for me
to refute in the same way I cannot
refuse possible that this bottle is
keeping all the poles that your
testosterone levels are 25 lower than
here no no he's the 40 he's what skews
it to 25. and um and this isn't just it
has now become can we lock the doors
just it has been wrapped into a much
larger narrative and
um and so when they hear disinformation
they say Oh you mean like Hunter laptop
which actually turned out to be true
okay a couple of things first off
it's not just about the hunter Biden
laptop okay it's about the constant
suppression of information and not
misinformation suppression of
information for example us with Kerry
lakeon biggest election stream of all
time 2016. they decided we're not going
to sorry 20 uh well 2016 and 2020. they
said you're not going to be allowed to
do midterm so it ended up being the
biggest election stream off of the
platform that is YouTube that
suppression of information because
Carrie Lake had a problem with the
voting methodology specifically in a
primary that she won we were removed for
that it's suppressing people who say you
know what I don't think that keeping
children at home for years with covet is
beneficial I think the net negatives
outweigh the net positives in other
words it's not just about the hunter
Biden laptop story how would the
election landscape have changed when you
take into account what at this moment in
time
because the election was taking place
um there was never going to be a vaccine
according to the DNC Donald Trump didn't
do anything for covet
it came from a wet Market
uh the CDC and the who were to be
trusted and the Republican party was a
party that was a anti-science at this
point in time and by the way uh Joe
Biden was of course beyond the scope of
any type of corruption because no one
even knew about Hunter Biden it's all of
it now let's just narrow it down to the
hunter Biden laptop story and this is
the straw man that Jonah Goldberg and
David French and these people use they
said oh it's a private company it's not
a private company if they're doing the
government spitting oh I don't
necessarily know that the hunter Biden
laptops where I would have changed the
election it absolutely would have but
we're not just talking about Hunter
Biden that was just the most egregious
example in which they were caught but
let's just narrow it down to that
remember when I say don't trust the
experts Jonah Goldberg doesn't know his
thumb if you have children I'm sorry
doesn't know his thumb from his dead
dick because according to the polls
we've talked about this you can
reference all of these at lottery.com 17
of Biden voters themselves said they
would have changed their Vote or not
voted if they had known about the laptop
story and the contents they're in if you
take that into account this is just the
hunter Biden laptop issue not the fouchy
issue not the vaccine issue not the mask
issue not the homeschooling issue not
the Ukraine issue not the Chinese issue
just the hunter Biden laptop sorry
taking that into account that would have
changed Arizona that would have changed
Georgia Nevada Michigan New Hampshire
Pennsylvania Wisconsin Michigan you just
change a little more than half of those
and the election changes
here's another argument they make well
the Dems weren't in control at that time
the Democrats so it doesn't really
matter they didn't have any power over
Twitter again the DNC is the official
wing of the democratic party Nancy
Pelosi and Joe Biden of course the de
facto representative of the democratic
party of course it shouldn't only be
people who are currently in government
though the DNC encapsulates that too but
people seeking the most powerful role of
government namely the president of the
United States
according to Tybee just to be clear on
this by the way who's not a conservative
this system wasn't balanced it was based
on contacts because Twitter was and is
overwhelmingly staffed by people of one
political orientation there were more
channels more ways to complain open to
the left far more meaning Democrats than
the right this is something by the way
keep in mind too with all this
misinformation going out there and uh
conservatives being suppressed we need
to be able to fight back of course
people say well why don't you just go
create your own Twitter
okay well then maybe they remove it from
the App Store
right or what happens that's no longer
searchable whether it's parlor whether
it's Rumble whether it's actually
Twitter now go and create your own or
you know what hey at the very least
Kaylee Mack she was obviously press
secretary yeah she was removed just from
mentioning the hunter Biden story so
when you have Twitter who has provided
protections under Section 230 as a
public utility and they are removing the
people in government who are tasked with
ensuring that you receive accurate
information at what point
do we say okay it's no longer a private
entity it used to be that the government
was in a position of power and they
would have strong men in Industry right
to to enforce their unfair laws
legislation right to enforce what
basically uh ended up benefiting those
at the top it's the exact opposite now
it's the Elites in power who are worth
far more than these individuals in
government who now have the government
enforcing their wishes and it's a quid
pro quo and I ask you do you feel free
and something else it's really important
to keep an eye especially as you go into
another election conservatives who
concede this territory
we're not looking to be removed from
YouTube but guess what we're fine with
it if it happens nothing would make me
happier than all of you heading on over
to rumble right now I cannot force you
to but when you have conservatives going
out as apologists for Twitter going out
as apologists for Facebook or demanding
that other conservatives play ball with
YouTube and that they they make sure
that they remain monetized these things
happen right and I'm not just talking
about David French we need to keep an
eye on that because we need to expect
better from people in our Movement we
need to be it's it's time to storm the
castle and we need to be a battering ram
we can't keep playing this oh well is it
a private company no it's not we've
proven Beyond any shadow of a doubt that
it's not when Republicans have power
conservatives have any kind of power
they need some legislative
accomplishments or change them boot them
and that includes people who've been on
this show I'm actually really excited to
have our next guest on the show before
we bring him on here uh we're going to
have a stinger and then we're going to
have a brief introduction for those of
you who missed
the interview that had taken place with
yay and Alex Jones uh there's so much to
get through and of course we'll be
taking some of your questions as we go
to mug Club later on but uh just to be
clear hey can we before we move on with
this just just to be clear please by the
way hit the share button hit the rumble
button hit like whatever it is Tim that
you want them to hit right now for the
algorithms uh because YouTube is not
going to want you to see this just just
go ahead and pick one browse this by
analysis if I say two or three he's like
oh it's like a lion tamer with three
prongs in the stool
just to be clear before we have Alex
Jones on we discussed this topic
do we all agree here Hitler bad
yes absolutely good okay good yeah here
we go there we go there we go yeah yeah
Hitler bad right that's the contest none
of you are just keeping on keeping up
appearances no no no we all genuinely
believe really bad that Hitler was a bad
guy you know it was National Socialist
disarmed the population yes big
government Progressive right maybe that
too yes
and by the way have you ever seen Ava
Braun come on
one day blew his brains out I think
after he was married
it didn't take long it was worse than
the war so let's
bring on Alex Jones
[Music]
we got the whole Quagmire I did find
some just entertainment sick
entertainment though watching him and
Alex Jones uh yesterday and it's just
funny because like Alex Jones was
treating Kanye West the way that
everyone else treats Alex Jones on
theirs
[Applause]
though
[Laughter]
well CNN says why people are evil Nazis
so I mean I I disagree with both
statements but I get the Trojan I don't
like the word evil next to Nazis I think
we need to look at
that oh my goodness just because you
don't like one group doesn't mean yeah
but look I love Jewish people but I also
love Nazis
oh man well I have to disagree with that
I like Hitler I don't like Hitler and I
know you're trying to be shocking with
that I'm not trying to be shocking I
like Hitler I do not I the the Holocaust
is not what happened let's look at the
facts of that and Hitler has a lot of
redeeming quality perfect answer for the
ADL
they are gonna have to listen up what we
did is we brought Netanyahu with us
I'm in the Twilight Zone right now it
was bad it was bad for traffic
okay
I had no idea your voice is going to
sound like that and then Yahoo well CNN
says why people are evil Nazi so I mean
I I disagree with both statements but I
get the Frozen I don't like the word
evil next to Nazis I think we need to
look at
oh my goodness just because you don't
like one group doesn't mean yeah but
look I love Jewish people but I also
love Nazis
oh man well I have to disagree with that
all right Mr Jones thank you for being
with us sir I felt we needed to include
that context uh boy it seemed like you
were holding on for a bumpy ride with
that interview do I do I have that about
right did you expect that in your
wildest dreams
uh no I didn't and I didn't say what he
could talk about but I said can we just
try to bring people together and and you
know talk about real issues like human
trafficking and Fentanyl and how you
want to bring jobs back to America and
really see the deeper side of you and
not just sound bites
and they were like yeah in fact he
doesn't want to even get into that stuff
right away
sit in the same Studio
I mean on Thursday bam and I thought he
was joking at first and here's the deal
he pulled up from the office and got out
of the vehicle in the get mask
and so
I didn't know what to say and I said
pull your mask off let me see it's
really you and it was him he puts the
mask he unzips the mask and then it's
really creepy in person with a mask yeah
and then I mean really I would see this
as a it's almost like a giant trolling
operation really he was a super high on
adrenaline when he did it he feels
really good about it and he
I don't think I was a very good
historical knowledge about World War II
either uh so I mean he really is in in
love with uh all of that uh design which
so much of what the Nazis design ended
up being brought over here with
Operation Paperclip so so it was bad
that yay says he loves Hitler uh then it
even worse than our own government
brought tens of thousands of Nazis into
World War II to run most of major
agencies so sure I
but I did notice that you tried to bring
in the concept of I'm trying to remember
the the term Hitler uh the man was it
the man yet to come what was the what
was the uh the man to come becoming man
the coming man and I remember yes
exactly the coming man sorry forgive me
but um it's something with which I'm
familiar and I remember you asked him a
very pointed question you said you don't
want to be that coming man and it was
very clear to me that regardless of
where people line up here on any of this
and of course I'm anti-hitler and I know
that you are and I'm really glad the
Allies beat the Nazis he was not
familiar with that and so it does
concern me that if he's going to go out
and make these statements were you
concerned sort of understanding or being
around his his close inner Social Circle
that they really aren't doing a good job
in ensuring that he's informed when he
goes out and discusses these issues
he is very forceful and has a big
personality and it's really hard to get
a word in edgewise kind of like Trump
and you know people think I have a big
personality but I'll actually be quiet
sometimes and I'm not you know put him
down for that he was like a whirlwind
you couldn't shut him up he was going to
say what he was going to say and I was
bringing up historic real things about
the Nazis that my family you know who
were in World War II told me about oh
that's true we saw that in Germany or we
saw that uh in Italy again both my
grandfathers almost died both of them
World War II I almost don't exist
because of it uh and they you know they
talked about what the Nazis were like
and uh my mom's uh dad also worked on
some black budget weapons programs in
the 50s and 60s and just said that he
meant some military bases uh that had
Nazis on them and they were very very
arrogant and he didn't like having to
work with them in these in these some of
these programs sound like eight years
old hearing my grandfather in Austin
Texas sitting around the kitchen table
bitching about you know Nazis and uh
working on secret web happens programs
and how arrogant they were and how much
he hated the government bringing them in
here so that's the real thing that's
going on so my dislike of Nazis really
comes from my grandfathers who both
didn't like him very much right well let
me ask you this um what was it when you
had obviously there's the numbers aspect
because he's he's a huge name right now
in the media what was it that you were
um looking to achieve or what were you
hoping would be the end goal what would
be the ideal scenario with this
interview with with yay because
obviously it went viral across the media
but bringing him in what were you hoping
was was going to come of it
well I was while I was listening to you
do a great job of breaking down that
this whole Hunter laptop thing and the
Twitter files are a lot bigger than just
Hunter Biden it's it's everything
they've been censoring I was thinking
what I want to say about yay first and
it's just this I really thought I could
come in here and shut up at first and
let him get it out of his system even if
he did it right I was saying hey let's
do something different let's you know
let's show them your intellectual side
let's let you know let's get into a
bunch of issues and I had all these
issues in front of me he goes why don't
you just set those aside we're not
getting into that I was like okay he's
let me know he's in control and so I
figured after an hour at least he would
let me kind of then bring up some topics
I wanted uh but you kind of had the
salacious crumb uh the Baby Hitler uh of
Nick Fuentes over there uh you know that
was a joke Jimmy Kimmel made like where
have I seen that foreign
sitting there but seriously I didn't
know that Nick Fuentes was really a Nazi
lover yeah I I'd had him on over the
years three or four times whenever he
was being debanked or censored and he
would be like no I'm not a Nazi I just
care about white people's rights so I
think this this whole thing was a real
coming out uh and I'll be honest with
you uh especially with the point-test
thing and I'll still have point this on
I believe in the First Amendment uh but
there's a real creepy factor with this
Hitler stuff that I also noticed that
Richard Spencer came out and said yay
blue Jones away because Jones is really
controlled by the liberal narrative that
Hitler's bad but those of us that know
the dark powerful beauty of Hitler and
and of the darkness and of the strength
and it's like some homoerotic you know
thing over Hitler that is kind of what's
going on there's this Hitler fetish and
no I'm not into dudes and fancy you know
peacock military uniforms that by the
way got 22 2 million Germans killed so
the biggest killer of Germans in history
of you like Germanic people and I'm you
know I'm basically half German I have a
lot of German Roots is Hitler Hitler was
a disaster Hitler was an occultist
Hitler was a pedophile Hitler was
horrible screw Hitler burning hell
Hitler and the left uses Hitler to push
their communist agenda that is basically
just as bad and authoritarian to call
all of us Hitler and so people are so
sick of being called Hitler they go hey
if Hitler's so powerful let's just say
we're with Hitler and that's what these
people are doing and I felt like I was
sucked in to a giant publicity stunt now
now I'm I'm not mad at either person I
understand that they probably even
believe what they're doing but no I saw
a whole bunch of programs like the young
turds and all of them say Jones is just
mad they let the secret out Jones likes
Hitler no I hate authoritarians I hate
Communists I hate ggping I hate Hitler I
hate Mao seitung I hate Joseph uh you
know Stalin I hate Fidel Castro I hate
Hugo Shabbat yeah I love George
Washington I love Thomas Jefferson I
love American strength and freedom and
power and Christianity and open
societies and capitalism and free speech
and I want it back now so bird and hell
Hitler and Stalin and Mal burning Hells
what I told Piers Morgan Hitler took the
guns Stalin hey Mal took the guns and if
you try to take our guns 1776 will
commence again you are my yay right now
see I'm I'm you and you're Yay see I
think you have some power I think you
have some empathy for what I have to do
sometimes when you're on by the way Alex
don't do that thing where your Monday
Morning Quarterback can take credit for
it Hitler was already in Hell burning
before you said that that's right okay
that's not because you called foreign
exactly but no no look um I understand
exactly where at first I thought you
were going to say the biggest killer of
Nazis were the uniforms because that's
how we went in I thought you were going
to say like Hugo Boss uniforms were made
of asbestos but no I I agree with you
and here's the thing you have people you
have people trying to defend it saying
well and and there's validity to this
Kanye West said I love everybody he
didn't say he hated anybody he said I
love Jews I love Hitler but he did go
out of his way to praise actions of
Hitler while condemning actions of Jews
in this sort of General monolith and he
did actively deny the Holocaust so to
act as though it was an equivalency of I
love everybody that's not what happened
with that interview now if people out
there want to say hey he has every right
to love Hitler of course and if you say
I agree with him when he says he loves
Hitler and that the Holocaust didn't
happen fine but to act as though there
was this equivalency you know on on your
show and it's in its totality sure he
said he loved everyone but he did have
specific praise for some totalitarian
dictators
I love Hitler I think he had an orgasm
over there well that's just how he
sounds when he raps I love Hitler huh
but he um I did it was one of those
things where let me ask you this do you
think that ultimately it kind of ends up
hurting
it kind of ends up hurting people who
are out there advocating for free speech
when we're saying we are not Nazis and
the guy goes out and just puts on a mask
and says actually I do love Nazis and
actually the Holocaust doesn't happen it
does make it hard for people out there
because look you're a lot of things Alex
an anti-semite is not one of them if
people have looked at you historically I
don't even think many people have
leveled that accusation against you if
anything you've seen anti-semites people
who legitimately hate Jews and I don't
mean people who don't believe that we
should be sending a bunch of money to
Israel I mean people who legitimately
hate Jews have accused you of being
controlled Jewish opposition for a very
long amount of time
so well that's the thing and here's the
deal
I don't like MS-13 but I'm not against
Central Americans uh I don't like the
New Black Panther Party that's like a
black KKK uh but but I don't blame black
people so Jews are a very diverse group
for anybody that actually studies
politics and geopolitical systems
there's a whole bunch of factions in
Israel constantly fighting with each
other and assassinating each other uh
the Jews over there have some of the
most Draconian you know vaccine rules in
the world if they're so special why do
they have all that so it's really not
true are there powerful mafias are there
powerful groups in Hollywood that
happened from a certain group absolutely
and do we see those groups supporting
leftist garbage intermediate am I
irritated by those groups do I like the
ADL trying to take our Free Speech no
I'm a big critic of the ADL and they
single me out at their big events just
two weeks ago with the head of Pfizer
and two years ago with uh Sasha bear
Cohen saying I'm evil I'm dangerous I
need to be silenced but there's all
sorts of groups trying to silence my
speech not just the ADL so it's it's
really what it is scriptures and by the
way when we say these groups we mean
anti-freedom groups and we don't just
mean we do not mean just to be clear
George Soros is a second generation
atheist okay let's be clear about that
so to actually [ __ ] yeah I mean 100
clear but at the same time I don't I'm
not saying you're doing this I get you
half because they'll lie I'm not
tiptoeing around this I what I'm saying
is I am critical of all of the anti-free
speech Yes Pro tyranny groups you know
last time I checked Tim Cook's not
Jewish he's working with communist China
to suppress their people last time I
checked Gigi pings the biggest dictator
in history his re his Communist Regime
going back to Mao has killed more people
than Hitler ever thought about they they
spent 100 million so but again I don't
dislike Asian people my sister is Corey
and adopted and I love her we you know
uh when I was 14 years old we adopted
from Korea when she was six months old I
love my sister I love Asian people but I
am scared as hell as easy ping and his
50 million man army uh and I'm
definitely upset about it and so again
if there were if there was some country
with a billion and a half Jews in it
uh they were promoting freedom and like
America used to be I'd try to go move
there but if there was a country of a
billion and a half Jews promoting world
government and death camps and and
forced injections I would say I'm
against that regime not because they're
Jewish but because this is libertarian
same thing with easy ping I mean it is
the most evil regime in history it is
our main foe we are in grave danger and
again nobody says oh you don't like GG
pink because you don't like Asians it's
it's all a fraud yeah I hate the
Communist Chinese party because I uh my
heart goes out to the Chinese people I
think Gerald Gerald has a question for
you and I appreciate you taking the time
because I know I know that was a tough
seat to be in Alex we could there was
there was a moment on your face where
you look like the boom goes a Dynamite
Kid where you were like
yeah so I just wanted to dive into the
Christian thing just a little bit
because people are conflating this
Christianity thing with people on the
far right that espouse these
anti-semitic views and even uh yay said
you know I I love everybody well that's
and you said it too you said not that
you love everybody that you're a
Christian right just declaring like I am
a Christian I don't like these things
Christ said he loved the sinner but
hated the sin right he always called
people out for for their sins just to be
clear did Kanye call Hitler out for any
of his sins on your show
well let's be clear and that's what
Kanye didn't get was why and I try to
put him down but I don't think he has a
fifth grade education about the Nazis
and I'm gonna try to meet with him again
and actually show him some real history
about his own writings because Hitler
was anti-christian Hitler was an
occultist he wanted to eradicate
Christianity some of the top Nazis uh in
the party did now later when he took the
country over did some Nazis wear crosses
on their shirts absolutely people mixed
it together it's like he might have a
Texas sting and then an American flag
thing or an army thing yeah yeah yeah
they co-opted it and and sure the
Catholic church was taken over by the
Nazis I mean they they ran Italy they
ran Germany so they went along with it
I'm not defending the Catholic church
right but the idea that Hitler was a
Christian or that Hitler was born a
Christian and all this stuff Adolf
Hitler was a deep occultist in his own
writings in his own words that's why
they used runes in their uniforms it's
everything he did was about
once they had a worldwide Aryan Master
race in control of all the slave races
uh the Uber mentioned over the little
slaves the Supermen over the slaves yeah
they were going to eradicate
Christianity they want an earth warship
uh blood and soil if you want to see
what they did There's footage now on uh
Twitter of Ukrainian Azog battalions
cutting themselves getting in a tomb a
six foot grave
bleeding into the blood getting out
hailing you know who but they hail Odin
and then they go over and put their
hands on out and they've all got
swastikas on their arms that's a real
blood and soil Nazi ritual that Hitler
invented that the SS did so when you see
the Azog Battalion they're doing SS
rituals they're not Christian they're
co-opted Norse Germanic uh Viking
religion mixed with the Nazis yeah one
of the other reasons that I know these
groups are not Christian Alex is because
the entire Bible from the very beginning
to the very end is God's Redemption plan
for us but specifically the Jewish
people and God is not done with him he
promises them an opportunity to come
back and have a final chance that's the
entire Book of Revelation most of the
Bible is about the Redemption of the
Jews and So for anybody out there to
espouse Christianity and say I'm
anti-semitic and that this stuff wasn't
bad they haven't read the book they are
not amongst us they are wolves in
sheep's clothing and by the way my final
point on this was you've talked about
the history in World War II and he's
like well Hitler invented the microphone
and he did this and he did this and he
did this and he said highways in the
microphone that I'm using yes I think he
maybe means the Autobahn like roads were
around before they were but I mean his
highway system that you know the Hugo
Boss stuff the Rockets I get all that he
doesn't mention the fact that he did
things that would make the Egyptians
blush with the people that they killed
to build the pyramids I get it maybe
aliens did it as well but I don't think
he understands how many people's lives
were that's why they have to deny it
that's why there has to be a holocaust
denial component and and and this is
first off before I move on to this
because there's so much to unpack here
Alex how do you think the Press has has
covered it and I don't mean you I think
that yeah I don't mean of course they'll
try and Tarn feather you but I'm saying
do you think that this the way the Press
has said that hey Kanye West yay on Alex
Jones went off and was very obviously
incredibly anti-semitic do we think that
in this case was the Press partially
right in other words are they completely
misrepresenting it or when you were
sitting there did did you feel as though
um this is probably not productive for
him
look
I like
Kanye West I like yay I I think he
really means well
um you know I don't know if Nick Fuentes
believes what he's saying and doing Nick
says a lot of really good stuff I agree
with uh once I heard him endorse that he
thinks Hitler's great I lost a lot of
respect for him because I know Nick's
really smart uh and I'm not saying yay
isn't smart but you know he's he's kind
of a savant uh and you know has a lot of
talent stuff and so yeah I I think in
the long run
uh yay wants to be a big revolutionary
he wants to hit the barbed wire as he
said he said you're Terminator one we're
Terminator 10. and I just really think
at the end of the day that that's not
the case the left have adopted so many
of the actual Nazi tactics of control
and their whole system of lockdowns what
you see in China big groups of people by
the tens of thousands being marched
together being led by one Pied Piper in
the whole white white medical uniform
that's that you know that's the real
type Audiology that the Nazis were
striving for and we know that Hitler
and of course Joseph Goebbels wrote
about how this is public they wanted to
take over England and kill H.G Wells and
kill Bertrand Russell and others because
the hwls and Bertrand Russell had a
competing authoritarian World Government
leftist Model that the Nazis were
competing with and they saw themselves
as you said as socialist but a different
brand of it and so I happen to know for
a fact that the left and the tactic
that's what George Harwell wrote 1984
about George Harwell was number two in
the propaganda arm of British
intelligence in World War II he'd been a
communist before that in the Spanish
Civil War been a hero in Heavenly
wounded but then when he actually got at
the top of the British uh socialist
society
and recognize that that actually Stalin
was being funded by the West there was
actually a war against the individual in
the future and that Hitler had been
wound up by British intelligence not not
run by them but actually you know built
up and given power and funding early by
the big Banks he realized that there was
a global authoritarian system that
operated under different names but
basically had the same goal total power
and control and reason I know that is
not just reading 1984 probably eight
nine times but I've read the writings
the essays uh in several big compendiums
of George Harwell right before he died
in 1949. uh he finished uh 1984 like
1947 uh but he died about a year and a
half later and so George Orwell had this
view of it as well he thought the Nazis
were the ultimate Evil he fought them
before World War II in Spain and against
Franco and then he later learned there
was a more evil group of Fabian
socialist uh British intelligence
basically Specter uh what you see in the
James Bond movies uh James Bond is
Specter and I'm not saying all the
British intelligence but that British
Empire model that merged with America at
Bretton Woods and then America became
the world Empire at that point that
system is full spectrum dominance where
they want to control all the major
groups and then play them off against
each other in a hegelian dialectic can I
jump in here with three things first off
I do encourage people no no I do
encourage people to um uh go and
research you know Orwell and also by the
way the catalonians because this is
something where people will try and use
it as an example of successful socialism
right in the 1930s say oh anarchosyntic
socialism go read what happened with
Orwell and read how that collapsed and
the kinds of pressures and basically
there were still factions of Warring
socialists because I was taught that in
University I was taught that in college
that that was a good example of
socialism which lasted all but under
half a decade the other thing is Kanye
West said if you're Terminator one he's
Terminator 10. I don't think he
understands how progressively shittier
the Terminator sequels have gotten after
Terminator two so that's actually a
compliment to you but here's something
else look you and I you know that I
disagree with you on some things and I
agree with you on on a lot just with you
on some but I do think you're very
consistent in your approach to what you
believe morally to be corrected and
correct here's my issue with some of the
stuff that's going on with with yay and
I and I don't really I don't believe
there's hate in his heart like you said
I think that there's probably some
ignorance because
and the reason I hold out hope is I see
him he's very pro-life and he talks
about Eugenics and he talks about Sanger
and Planned Parenthood and the genocide
that's taking place against black babies
but then he doesn't seem to draw the
connection that that is something of
course that Hitler was incredibly
enthusiastic about impermanence let's go
further let's go further Hitler said
Hitler said Margaret sanger's book was
his Bible look this up and they use the
Margaret Sanger and the and the Cold
Springs Harbor New York Rockefeller run
Eugenics laboratory as their defense at
Nuremberg because it had been the
Rockefellers and Margaret Sanger that
helped set up the Kaiser Vellum
Institute in the late 1920s that then
funded Hitler and was the Brain Trust of
the Nazi race Sciences so what you said
is 110 true and that's what I would try
to tell him also once we got off air so
I'm going to try to meet with him
sometime when he's not his manic I'm
going to try to explain to him do you
think can I ask you that I know you're
not a doctor I'm not a doctor did you
did you sense I have I've had bipolar
people in my family did and he has said
that he was diagnosed with that did you
see maybe perhaps some some signs of of
mania and this isn't concern trolling
because I really hope he has people
around him who are who are helping him
and care about him no I mean I don't
think he's mentally ill I think he's
enjoying himself you know they have all
these diagnosis terms I mean I'm pretty
manic I have a lot of energy
so does anybody that's successful I
don't know but but he he
did seem to be very very
people can go to infowars.com because
remember I'm more censored to anybody
else out there they can go to
infowars.com
and they can also go to band.video
and find the full interview and actually
see it for themselves in in context I I
I can't bring myself to go watch it
again because I can't stand watching
myself but I've watched a lot of
excerpts and
I just think what happened was he
decided to go all the way he said he
decided to try to be as shocking as
possible and say screw the world and he
and then once he started pressing on the
dopamine button uh saying the things he
said he just couldn't stop and so it
became uh you know just a situation of
redlining the engine the entire time he
was on yeah yeah it seems like that uh
that might be the case
um all right well look I actually do
want to ask you about some things that
we probably have to discuss uh on mug
Club only uh let me just leave this one
thing because I do think this is
important because look we do know that
there are you have many Jewish fans I
have many Jewish fans and by the way I
don't just mean zionists I mean they're
a Jewish libertarian fans who believe
who support Israel certainly in contrast
to Hamas and Iran and people who want to
wipe them off the face of the map but
think that we shouldn't be providing as
much foreign aid I don't believe that
that's anti-semitic
um I do think it's important and I think
what happens is people are imprecise
when they say Jews it's very different
from for example black Americans or if
you you for example like you mentioned
sort of people from Mexican Americans
Jew can mean a Jewish person can be
Jewish by faith meaning they practice a
faith they can be Jewish by ethnicity
and they can be Jewish by culture and to
lump them all in there is a very big
difference between yes I do think
there's a conversation to be had about
the secularists in the entertainment
industry and if someone wants to
conflate that with anti-Semitism what
they're doing is saying oh is it because
you're saying because they're Jewish no
no I'm saying for the same reason that
there are plenty of non-jewish people in
the entertainment industry who are
involved with grooming who are involved
with by the way uh the degeneracy of
society the only reason that there tend
to be people who are largely atheist
Jews in the entertainment industry or
for example in Banks which compared to
them as a percentage of the population
is Jews for the same reason that there
are plenty of Jewish doctors and
scientists and Asian doctors and
scientists because they're very
hard-working industrious people who
value studying who value higher
education and who value those fields of
work we need to be clear when people are
discussing these things that there's a
huge difference so let me elaborate on
that before you switch to mug Club
because I think this is very important
the left has wrapped itself in we're
Captain America we're fighting the Nazis
and everybody else are Nazis on the side
that's made a lot of people get mad and
say okay screw you I'm a Nazi I think
that's what's happening when Nick foyin
says people like Kanye West yay West
but I'll tell you I've been attacked
massively by the ADL all these other
groups and they wrap themselves in we're
Jews and then they attack me in the name
of Jews which is then making a lot of
people think well Alex Jones is good you
must be bad so I know there are a lot of
Jews out there conservative Jews and
others that have sent letters in the ADL
saying leave Tucker Carlson alone stop
calling him an anti-semite it's not true
or stop calling Donald Trump as
anti-semite it's Preposterous he's a
great friend of Israel and so it's the
weaponization of the left that is
actually giving support to real Nazis by
watering the whole thing down it's very
very very very very serious and the ADL
knows exactly what they're doing so I
think people have a right to say
whatever they want as long as they don't
call for violence I think of the Azog
battalion's on there doing literal hit
rituals on Twitter you know uh yay
should still be on there so so I'm not
defending any of the censorship any of
that uh I'm just simply saying the left
weaponizing World War II that ended 76
years ago 70 how many years ago is very
very dangerous on the left saying at
universities the national news you cover
it more than anybody that being White's
inherently bad and teach and teaching
courses on that is going to then make
Nazi sound legitimate because here's a
bunch of leftist academics and Hollywood
people a lot of Jews literally trying to
teach the majority minorities who are
now the majority that owe white people
who aren't a certain you know a
religious group you know white people
accept Jews are all bad people this is
this is hitlerian this is racist this is
race-based Politics on the other side
and I know almost all Americans no
matter what color they are disagree with
it almost all Jews disagree with it but
when we look at the media and just turn
it the other way it sounds like Hitler
when they're on MSNBC saying white
people are inherently bad right and it's
going to be great when there's no more
white people that needs to stop that is
hitlerian in the name of fighting Hitler
do you see the psyop yeah no I think
you're right and also you know where
I've never heard that kind of rhetoric
I've been to many a synagogue just to be
clear many never heard that kind of
hatred coming from observant Jews and
Orthodox Jews and I think it's important
to delineate it is infowars.com we're
going to go to Mud Club oh I got to tell
you right again folks Ultra Orthodox
Jews as they call them are super
right-wing pro-america I mean I see
their views I'm like 98 exactly and in
Israel the leftist Jews when they're in
power persecute the right-wing Jews
right no exactly it's not a monolith and
people need to be clear about and I
think that we need to be able to have
honest conversations about all of these
issues and I just sometimes I think that
it's overshadowed when someone is like
you said if you were I don't think you
were roped in uh to any kind of
publicity stunt as you said I don't
think you were used I think you're
you're clever enough to not allow that
to happen if it was a danger I knew it
was a danger but I believed it wasn't
going to happen I would have much rather
had it been a big story and it had been
coming together and an Awakening and
then have a relationship with yay
instead of him blowing up like a like a
son doing Supernova and and and burning
himself up I mean he didn't really hurt
info horses people know I'm not a Nazi
I'm like dude that's not good but at the
same time Pointes and I'm gonna get him
back on there and challenge him he's
just giggling too much like it's fun
watching this over here he's not stupid
and and you know he he knows the history
here and and so I'm gonna have a debate
with Point test not a mean debate but
I'm going to get my history and get his
history and we're going to have a debate
about this because you know to admit the
truth about World War II look I mean I
told the story when they were here my
grandfather had his dad was German most
the rest of the family been in Texas
forever but his dad still spoke some
German and was only like second
generation in in Dallas and they were
Rich Germans up there and he owned the
big Chevy dealership all the rest of it
and they lived next to a super rich
German who was first generation who'd
moved here as a kid who was the inventor
one of the main inventors of
refrigeration they had big patents on
air conditioning he was super rich the
equivalent of a billionaire today
and and the fanciest part of Dallas
getting Like A Hundred Acre complex and
my grandfather would go over there and
and he would take her and work with in
this guy's invention shop reason my
grandfather after World War II got into
inventing and stuff and was involved in
some different projects and he watched
this guy who had blonde hair by the way
and blue eyes totally German you know I
quote Aryan he watched that guy
from the early 30s up until my
grandfather went off uh you know the
Army Air Corps and he watched that guy
get totally depressed you just shut up
well become reclusive and I think he
told me you don't tell my story twice
commit suicide later was because he
later learned the Nazis over the decade
that they were in power from 33 or you
know up were threatening to kill his
German relatives in Germany if he'd
secretly give him all their money so
that's what the Nazis did is they were
the most Cutthroat at the end of the war
they probably would have won if they
didn't spend half their time running
around stealing all the art including
the drapes they had whole giant cave
systems that they had people build just
to put the hordes of loot in yeah I mean
they were they were there and by the way
if the people back then this is the
thing it's one of those things where
people today Monday Morning Quarterback
and say I think they did a lot of good
things well guess what the people who
were held out as ambassadors back then
for Nazis well they were they were it
was done by force for example Max
schmelling and Joe Lewis Max schmelling
a lot of people know that Joe Jesse
Owens story Max schmelling and Joe Lewis
right schmelling was the Aryan
representative Joe Lewis for the United
States they were good friends for the
rest of their lives because Max
schmelling was not a Nazi did not
support what they were on board with now
I before we go to Mud Club it's
infowars.com and I'm hearing I don't
want people to misrepresent what you're
saying you just said you're not trying
to platform because you agree with them
you want to have Nick Fuentes on so you
can debate him and uh show where he is
wrong and I think that that is something
that is healthy otherwise people exist
in Echo Chambers infowars.com we're
gonna go to Mud Club because YouTube
there's no way we could do this here
Alex stay with us YouTube piss off thank
you Rumble
oh
foreign